Somebody help me!
(screams)
(upbeat rhythmic music)
(car honking)
(tire screeching car crash)
- [Man Voiceover] Somebody
call an ambulance.
(upbeat jazz music)
Not about this.
(fly buzzing)
(upbeat jazz music)
Ow!
Oh!
No.
(suspenseful orchestral music)
(screams)
Fuck, fuck fuck fuck fuck fuck.
(suspenseful orchestral music)
(phone buzzing)
(upbeat jazz music)
(insect claws scurrying)
(suspenseful orchestral music)
(menacing orchestral music)
(screams)
(screaming)
Ow!
(insect claws scurrying)
(upbeat jazz music)
(suspenseful orchestral music)
(insects claws scurrying)
Help.
Somebody help me!
Please!
(screams)
(insects claws scurrying)
(phone buzzing)
(ominous orchestral music)
(insects claws scurrying)
(screams)
(upbeat jazz music)
Oh no!
(screaming)